I watched uh your show the last thing he
told me yeah
um it's so nail biter edge of your seat
incredible Thriller we actually did a
giveaway of the book um here last year
um and I know this is the awesome Reese
Witherspoon
um and hello sunshine in her company and
they always find the best books and turn
it into the best TV shows we just talked
to Catherine Hahn I'm obsessed with her
new show that they're doing I watch
everything they do this is like all I've
wanted is the entertainment that comes
out of hello sunshine and this is no
different that it's so incredibly
compelling let's take a quick look
okay good morning Bailey can we go
I think I should get dressed first
Dad I'm gonna be late fails we're all
five minutes from school I know for a
fact first period it doesn't start for
20.
how about we start with good morning
gripping edge of your seat Thrillers
which I don't know who doesn't this
really is truly like one of those books
and shows it is at the same time there
is a love story at the middle of it
between a child who never thought she
would have a mother and a woman who
never thought she would have a child
they are stepmother and stepdaughter
they are they have an antagonistic
relationship and they're put in a
position because they're the man that
they share the father husband disappears
they have to figure some things out it
turns into a thriller they they are
questioning the whole time how well do
we know the people we love they have a
core belief that they share other than
that they share absolutely nothing but
in the process of trying to hunt hunt
down the truth they build a trust and a
friendship and they become found family
they become real family to each other
and joining us is
[Applause]
foreign
thank you for coming here we have been
fans of your book and
um for a while here at the show how are
you feeling about it like coming to life
and when you see the show
um as a springboard to your book how do
you feel about it you know I think I
could not be happier or more lucky and I
so appreciate the way you have embraced
the book here and
um as um you guys will will see from the
show everything comes down to Hannah
that's who it came down to in the book
and that's who it came down to your
character and there's no one who could
be Hannah the way this woman right here
is Hannah
it's so good and it it does as a mother
to daughters like it is a gripping story
watching you and this young girl try to
figure each other out and be on opposite
ends of the spectrum and watch you guys
come together it's so well done thank
you so much thank you so much
as one final birthday gift because I
know we're gonna go one more the entire
audience is gonna go home with their own
copy of the last thing
and then you can binge the show and you
can read the book
[Music]